the guy could have been was you know
complacent or or happy that he got
something right but I wanted to take it
by the neck and take it to the next
level I'm Gary Vaynerchuk
and I'm Director of Operations and
co-owner of Wine Library and hosts the
blind library TV we're an over fifty
million dollar a year business we have
over a hundred employees were one of the
most visited wide web sites on the
internet we are kicking butt a little
bit I've always dreamed crazy big I
fundamentally knew that the competition
out there was not ready for what I was
gonna bring to the table all right funny
tonight we're talking about going big
time sure buddy says I want to be big
but there are certain things you got to
do that you did some very specific steps
that we're gonna share tonight and the
first one to go from your case to 250
million cuz people just saw two million
it's okay is you got to find the hoopla
factor you say talk to me about the
hoopla factor you know you have to be
excited about what you're doing and so
if you have the hoopla factor it's
because you love what you do and so for
me it's be who you are be as transparent
and as real as possible
and that's gonna make you different cuz
everybody's different and so whether
it's an a personal brand or within your
store or whatever you're doing did you
do okay here's the history between
staying small and going big what was
your hoopla factor that got you there
the first small hoopla factor was
launching a website in 1997
winelibrary.com was launched nobody was
doing that in the wine retail business
the second thing was I was a little bit
of a freak show I was a seventeen you
know as a 20 year old kid that looked 13
and knew a lot about Burgundy you know
people came just to see that but more
importantly I invested very heavily in a
different product mix that everybody was
really worried about Bordeaux in
California and I saw Spain and Australia
coming on and so I would pump that and
get people excited about that so you got
to do it different there's got to be
some if you wanna go big and anything
you're doing in life you gotta say I
want to I want to do a little it's got
me some hoop on there the other thing
next thing you talk about is you got to
get ahead of the pulse yeah I mean
reading trends is death City USA say
that again
reading trends is death City USA you
need to be aware of trends and find them
and the way you do that is you get in
the pulse you get into the trenches I
would conversate with every customer
that walked through the store I answer
and read every email I
get everyday and it's a thousand plus a
day but what that gives me is a crazy Rd
I'm a research and development guy in my
own guts I know what's going on I know
what's coming next
I know Portugal's coming on the scene I
know Greek wines are gonna mean
something and the way I do that is by
working my face off and not reading
what's coming well one of those lines
also go in the opposite direction your
case everybody was on to California said
I'm gonna do Australian wines because I
saw that people were liking California
wine because they were fruitier and
bigger than Bordeaux well where was the
next fruity bigger version of California
it was Australia in Spain and so it
became a very obvious segue in palates
and I just knew that once they got
exposure you know the wine industry you
know ratings are very important and to
me it's once you get rated and reviewed
and people read about you you're in the
game and I knew it was just a matter of
time that once those wines got that kind
of press that they would be on the tip
of every tongue and so I embraced and
learned everything I could about him
speaking of learning the third thing you
saying I think this is 101 put your
chips on talent I want to make it big
how do you mean I grew my family
business from 4 million to 15 million in
a quick second 24 36 months and I was
paying myself 27 thousand dollars a year
I had employees making more money than
me and you're the normal demo of a 26
year old that maybe did something like
that is he's gonna want to have the car
and the place and I didn't I wanted to
reinvest you know too many people don't
understand sometimes you know people are
talking about what are you doing now to
me it's not about what you're doing now
it's about where you're going you know I
was a young guy I'm still a young guy I
want to accomplish crazy things and
there's no way I'm gonna cash in I'm
gonna reinvest with the people around me
absolutely it's hard you can't go wrong
betting on talent no it's more the
difference between staying small and
getting big and whatever you do in life
I just want to put this out there in
neon again is it's the people stupid
you're investing people will always come
back and you know what I'm gonna add one
little thing to that I think you need to
invest in people that have a certain DNA
you have to know their DNA I always like
you know you always hear people say
smarter than you and all that and that
makes a lot of sense but you are the
core right you're at the top there and
you need to be able to interact and more
importantly love the people you're
working with to some sort of level
because once you start creating that
family atmosphere that's wine library's
biggest secret that everybody loves each
other my building
and the person that's causing trouble
the one that doesn't understand how to
play with the other boys and girls
throughout their out I love their out
you talk about spreading your bets
around also another key thing to making
a big I'm a very big fan of not playing
in the playground that you're supposed
to I'm a wine guy and I don't go to wine
events I speak at technology conferences
I spoke at Facebook the other day Google
I want to be in six apart I want to be
in different places that you know people
are curious about wine I mean the people
that are into wine that wine scene I've
got that I've lived that that's been my
world I think it's imperative to be
involved in the social networks on the
Internet to be involved in the real
world all these internet guys love to
live just in the internet sometimes you
need to go out there and shake some
handcuffed a bees live interact that's
how you can spread it dramatically more
okay and the final one is social equity
Trump's private equity this is my
favorite I honestly can tell you in 2008
not in 2000 maybe not even in 2005 but
in 2008 and Beyond I would much rather
have a million friends then I used to
say a million dollars I've now changed
it to a million friends than ten million
dollars the social equity
the friendship what you know this word
of mouth how powerful is that more most
empower Feliz we are living in a world
where every person's word of mouth we
just so many more people and that to me
that is the homerun of where we are
today